У цьому купейному вагоні "Укрзалізниці -"
взірцеві чистота і порядок. Навіть у туалеті.
- Туалет має накладку
індивідуальну для кожного пасажира.
Приємний шок для пасажирів, які мають досвід
поїздок із тарганами, пацюками та у бруді.
- За інші вагони не можу сказати, але коли є хазяїн
на вагоні і на потязі, то тарганів і всього цього не буде.
Олена Кравченко - начальниця потягу Київ-Ужгород.
Вона визнає, що такі вагони в "Укрзалізниці"
можна порахувати на пальцях однієї руки.
Водночас жінка з понад 30-річним досвідом роботи на залізниці
як ніхто знає, як мотивувати провідників
і потяг добре до рейсу підготувати,
і пасажирів якісно й гостинно прийняти.
От тільки зберігати при цьому гарний настрій,
зізнається Олена, її бригаді стає дедалі важче.
Олена - лідерка одного з осередків галузевої профспілки
і вже місяць разом із колегами відвідує між рейсами різні акції протесту.
Профспілки виступають  проти законопроектів
щодо змін до трудового законодавства,
ініційованих депутатами правлячої партії.
Ці законопроекти, зокрема, передбачають
необов’язкову індексацію зарплати,
фактичне скасування державної гарантії
мінімальної зарплати не нижче прожиткового мінімуму.
Також просувається ідея відмови від 5-денного
робочого тижня з двома вихідними.
На думку Олени, якщо ці зміни будуть ухвалені,
на її підприємстві цілком можуть забути
про обіцянки підвищити зарплату і матимуть
законну можливість платити менше за більший обсяг роботи.
- По новому кодексу можуть зробити і 10 годин робочого часу,
і 8, і 9, і 6 днів. Тільки 24 години відпочинку.
Тобто годин буде більше відпрацювати
і немає гарантованої зарплати.
У провідника зарплата маленька - 7, 8, 9 тисяч.
Це дуже мало для України.
Коли буде цей закон, я на 100% впевнена,
що молодь наша поїде, вони всі виїдуть.
Депутати від партії "Слуга народу" заспокоюють профспілки і працівників:
мовляв, 40-годинний робочий тиждень залишається.
Просто законодавство треба зробити універсальним,
аби вивести з тіні, зокрема, фрілансерів та сезонних робітників,
мотивувати роботодавців підписувати з ними
офіційні договори, де можна прописувати різні умови.
Без прив’язки, приміром, до обов’язкових вихідних
чи то гарантованої відпустки, лікарняного,
до місця роботи, до кількості годин у ту ж саму зміну.
Провідник потягу Київ-Ужгород Назар Ільченко
сприймає це як карт-бланш для роботодавця
не виконувати трудовий договір, де прописано,
де, з ким, на якому рейсі він як провідник має працювати.
- Я не можу бути впевненим, що вийду саме в цю бригаду,
що поїду в поїздку, а не залишуся на якусь погрузку-вигрузку.
Мене можуть до відома не поставити, я можу стати простим вантажником.
У Діани Штиль, яка працює в "Укрзалізниці" 2 роки,
свої аргументи. Вона переймається, щоб жінки
після народження дітей не втратили
гарантоване наразі право сидіти вдома з дитиною від 3 до 6 років.
- Якщо приймуть нововведення, то жінка
після декрету тільки 126 днів має сидіти вдома.
Далі вона має наймати няню, яка доглядатиме дитину.
Так як зарплата невелика, то я не дуже  впевнена,
що всі це собі можуть дозволити.
Уряд і парламентарі правлячої партії
вважають чинний трудовий кодекс застарілим,
повним радянських пережитків, які необхідно усувати.
Експерт із трудового права Георгій Сандул не погоджується.
Цей кодекс, за його словами, зазнав уже понад 200 змін
і був удосконалений до більш сучасних стандартів.
А те, що його не виконують на 100%, каже Сандул, -
наслідок незадовільної роботи судової та правоохоронної систем.
Ухвалення нового законодавства, на думку експерта,
обмежить не лише права робітників, яких, наприклад,
зможуть звільнити без пояснення причин, а й права профспілок,
які, відповідно до ще чинного законодавства,
мають це звільнення узгоджувати.
- Ці законопроекти в принципі руйнують
систему соціального захисту трудових прав в Україні
та обмежують права на свободу об’єднання у профспілки,
що гарантовано  міжнародними актами.
Дана реформа робиться виключно в інтересах роботодавця -
транснаціональних корпорацій та великих фінансово-промислових груп.
- Турборежим уже перешел в турбобеспредел!
Всеукраїнське віче профспілок - можливо,
один із рідкісних випадків, коли офіційні галузеві профспілки
демонструють єдність із незалежними.
На думку профспілкових лідерів, їх хоче усунути,
зокрема, міністр розвитку економіки, торгівлі
та сільського господарства Тимофій Милованов.
Про необхідність профспілкової реформи
Милованов заявляв у інтерв’ю DW наприкінці 2019 року.
Мета реформи - ліквідувати недієві профспілки.
Натомість, наприклад, запровадити на підприємствах
посаду медіатора, який би міг врегульовувати
суперечки між роботодавцем і робітником.
- У нас країні 2 типи профспілок.
Один тип - незалежні профспілки,
а є ще в нас такі, знаєте, пострадянські  профспілки,
які насправді більше працюють на керівників підприємств,
продають в оренду, щось здають, щось мутять собі, знаєте, от таке.
Ті нічого насправді не роблять і не захищають робітника.
Як насправді дати можливість, щоб ці профспілки,
що справжні, були більше активні,
а ті профспілки, які є тільки на папері,
щоб вони не мали влади, от це ми не знаємо.
Почасти думки міністра поділяють і в деяких профспілках.
Щоправда, на Всеукраїнському віче сказати про це ризикнув
лише представник незалежної профспілки авіабудівників.
Веніамін Тимошенко звинуватив галузеві профспілки,
зокрема, в бездіяльності під час масового звільнення
кількох тисяч робітників в останні роки,
у відсутності дієвої реакції на підвищення пенсійного віку.
- Настав час
дати відповіді і відрефлексувати все, що стосується
розкрадання майна, розкрадань членських внесків.
Поки ми не займемося самоочищенням у профспілковому русі,
ми так і залишимося сировинною колонією
з безправним населенням усередині.
Тому, я вважаю, нам потрібно з’ясувати:
хто є профспілка і чим вона має займатися.
- Ви кричіть "ганьба" собі! Це стосується безпосередньо вас!
Олена Кравченко у профспілковому русі вже 7 років.
Почала з того, що через суд домоглася разом із колегами
поновлення на роботі після звільнення.
Її профспілка наразі працює під прапором
незалежних вільних профспілок. 55-річна жінка вважає:
якщо влада протисне заплановані зміни Трудового кодексу,
то просто порушить Конституцію.
- Якщо нова влада хоче щось поліпшити, то, можливо,
треба якось згідно з законом
поспілкуватися з профспілками, які працюють.
Не з верхівками профспілок, а з такими, як я.
Нас таких дуже багато - голів профспілкових "первичок".
Чому? Ми працюємо біля людей, з людьми.
Законопроекти про зміни у трудовому законодавстві
не пройшли широкого громадського обговорення.
Саме цього наразі вимагають профспілки.
Якщо законопроекти не будуть відкликані,
погрожують оголосити Всеукраїнський страйк.
І в цьому, попри численні розбіжності, усі профспілки єдині.